[Music]
hey everybody Welcome to the data
science hangout hope you all had a nice
Thanksgiving holiday if you celebrated
or a nice week regardless last week um
if this is your first time joining us
today so nice to meet you I'm Rachel I
lead customer marketing at posit if this
is your first hangout say hi in the chat
because we'd love to welcome you in
especially anybody joining For the First
Time The Hangout is our open space to
chat about data Science Leadership
questions you're facing and getting to
hear what's going on in the world of
data across different Industries and so
we're here every Thursday at the same
time same place unless it's a holiday if
you're watching this recording on
YouTube later and you want to join us
live there'll be a link to add it to
your calendar in the description
below at the data science hangout we're
all dedicated to making this a welcoming
environment for everybody so we love to
hear from everyone no matter your years
of experience titles industry or
languages that you work in it's totally
okay to just listen in here um but
there's also three ways you can jump in
and ask questions or provide your own
perspective to so you could raise your
hand on Zoom and I'll keep an eye out
here you can put questions in the zoom
chat and if it's something that you want
me to read instead you could put a
little star next to it and I'll know to
read that for you but we also have a
slido link too so you can ask questions
anonymously but with all of that thank
you so much for spending your Thursday
with us I'm so excited to be joined by
my co-host today Laura Gast data science
and analytics manager at Uso and Laura
I'd love to have you introduce yourself
and maybe share a little bit about your
role and something you like to do
outside of work yeah so uh hi everyone
thanks for having me here today um uh so
my role right now I work in the the
development operation side so basically
it's fundraising data um and like I'd
say 95% of nonprofit organizations um
our data is kind of everywhere and kind
of a little bit of a mess and as happens
with siloed information May or Silo
organizations maybe what we call one
thing in one database is not the same in
the other so bringing together all of
these different components and we have
multiple databases for incoming gifts
and making them all talk together to get
at the end of the day the question is
how much money did we raise this month
and from whom um and it seems like an
easy question but just like how many
clients do we have in our organization
uh it's usually more difficult than and
than you should then you think it should
be um and so um for those that don't
know Uso is United Services or
organization if you watched the movie
White Christmas Bob Hope sings it one of
those um we uh provide services for
currently serving military members and
their family um and uh so that's what I
do for my job my background actually is
an epidemiologist um but in 2020 I
stepped away from that for a bit um and
uh the thing I like to do outside of
this is uh outside of my work is
probably running marathons or playing
darts so those are my two fun fun things
that is awesome where's your favorite
Marathon location I love Chicago
marathon it's just it's big but not too
big it's not New York big 50,000 people
is too many people for me 30,000 is
plenty um and then it's always got great
weather and amazing crowds
so nice I love it well thank you so much
Laura for joining us here I get to start
out with some of the questions while we
wait for everything everybody to uh
weigh in with their questions but I know
you gave a great talk at the posit
conference on design and I'd love to
hear a little bit from you about that
like what is one of your favorite
lessons you like to share with people
about data visualization and information
design yeah so um my talk was exactly
that uh it's kind of my lessons learned
and trying to think about how humans
think when you're creating a report or a
data visualization or even a Excel file
just a table um because throughout my
career and again I've worked many
careers as an epidemiologist for several
different countries um the common thing
I came across was I thought I was saying
something but someone else thought I was
saying something else and so the flexing
those empathy muscles reflexing those
stepping outside of what you're seeing
muscles was one part of that um the
other part was I would have to present
both to you know a minister of Health
who had four and a half minutes for me
and at the end of that four and a half
minutes they had to sign off on a big
spend but also convince their policy
wonks who wanted to see all of the data
within it and I had to do that all of
that within that four minute window so
it's kind of bringing those two things
together and what I learned from that um
my favorite kind of instance of uh of of
this I guess um was oh let's pick this
one um so we were working on a uh rapid
response or rapid reporting system for
malaria in South Africa um South Africa
is almost to the point of eliminating
and so you get these like little pops
right so instead of countries that have
a lot where it's just always a lot and
sometimes it's higher and sometimes it's
lower but it's always going on in
countries that are eliminating it's very
very very very low and then it goes off
the charts and then you you react and
bring it back down and then it's low low
low off the charts and the important
thing to do is when it starts to go up
if you cut it off then it's going to
come back down right so you need to know
really quick quickly when you're
starting to approach that threshold
where everything's just going to kind of
go off the rails for a bit and uh
figuring out that whole system and how
to demonstrate that the system that we'd
spend a lot of time and money based on
like sending nurses sending smss right
because paper would take months to get
there um demonstrating that the system
that we only put in a few Sentinel sites
was actually going to catch that
threshold and while you know I'm making
this up the threshold would really be
100 cases in this large area we were
able to say at these two clinics based
on all of this past history we're we see
this thresholds first there and so nine
cases at that clinic really is the
problem and so how do you convince
people who are used to thinking 100 is
the problem that nine is the problem and
so demonstrating these these Graphics
one over the other this is what the path
looks like usually this is what the path
looks like at this first our Sentinel
stations so knowing that that's
happening at our centralist station and
then tying that again to the the
economic impact of letting it get here
versus cutting it off here um to that
whole story but putting those two
visuals together we actually came up
with one single image which was those
two lines where you could see our
Sentinel stations as as being those
those highlights so that was one of my I
was really excited that we were able to
nail that that one picture to tell the
whole story and then we could keep
talking but we wanted people to go oh
and then come with us on the rest of it
rather than go like ah charts whatever
just tell me when I need to do stuff um
so it's my one good example I can think
of that's great thank you I wanted to
also just give a shout out to your new
blog that you
uh thank you posted um because just when
you were mentioning like the story in
that I was thinking of like there's a
line in that blog post I share that says
those who tell the stories rule the
world that you wrote um and you talked
about how like we're wired to remember
stories better than a list of facts um
and
so thinking about like our own
presentations that we're giving how do
you actually like come up with the story
that people are going to remember yeah
absolutely so just a note on the blog I
got covid which is why I didn't there's
not a new one from last month so there
are more coming they're just half
written and I slept for two weeks
instead of doing other work and I'm
digging myself out so more are coming I
just they're not there yet um but
talking about humans as storytellers um
you don't remember the bullet points you
don't remember the numbers well few
people remember the numbers when you're
given a presentation right you remember
oh yeah last week my co-worker Sam um he
gave that presentation on that project
and I remember the red line went up
right oh they must have been doing well
I think he mentioned something about
them working with that data field and it
was going going well and they solved
something with that other thing you're
not remembering it went up 14% you're
not remembering he joined it and on the
31st of 2018 that's when the data type
changes you might remember it but you're
remembering the theme right and you
remember that Sam solved this problem
you remember that Sam solves this
problem by talking to Paul you know
you're remembering the the the meat of
it and while you're hearing that
presentation from Sam Sam is connecting
all the dots for you so that you're
brought along in that story each of
those little story points is supported
by the facts of we went up 14% it was
December of 2018 those little factoids
but really what you're doing is carrying
someone through a story so you can say
this is the problem we started with this
is where we ended up and anybody in your
audience should remember the gist of
your your story and then they'll have it
in their head when they need to come
back and solve a similar problem or hire
you to come in and solve the problem for
them
um so that that kind of idea but humans
by Nature are storytellers we don't we
don't necessarily remember the pieces we
remember an arc and if you can put your
facts into an arc um then you're you
have a better memory of it and if you
think you don't do arcs if you've ever
written an academic paper what is an
introduction background methods
materials results and discussion it's
introduction and then you have all the
components of a story the day num the
conclusion everything everything build
is kind of into that Ark anything that
lasts Works in there so that's kind of
where I've my blog my presentation are
sort of in those worlds I love this and
I'm seeing a lot of uh reactions to this
in the chat here so I didn't want to
jump off this topic if somebody had a
specific follow-up question on this too
or stories where it worked for you I
always love hearing stories from others
absolutely okay we'll give you time to
weigh in you can put you could share
them in the chat too um but I did see a
slido question oh NOP it wasn't slido
let's see CA I see you asked a question
do you want to jump in hi thanks um
that's really nice because I enjoy
storytelling and I think science is all
about
storytelling um and how effectively do
we do that um so I guess um recently uh
one of my relatives uh was diagnosed
with a neurodiversity condition and I
was just C ious like how have you
incorporated or what kind of tools have
you Incorporated in your own version of
Storytelling to really accommodate for
more
neurodiverse uh individuals uh
individuals who may have faced stress or
trauma and don't necessarily see the
data in the same way as um someone uh
with a different uh neurological
background um yeah absolutely so I'll
take it kind of in two parts so one is
the I have a family member who was
recently diagnosed with a Cancer and I
was I'm this person's patient advocate
so I was reading the documentation so as
to not stress this person um and so from
that side of things I am always careful
to use um warning symbols in a very
careful way right so think about the
color
red one of my organizations main colors
is red I actively work against using
that color anywh where I don't need to
go bad I will only want red because we
we're in a western culture there are
different colors for different cultures
but especially in in in the western USC
Canada EU type or UK type situation red
is bad green is good blue is cool as you
know is relaxed is is is even is
Baseline so I am really careful to use
those colors in this report for my
family member they Ed red as the heading
because red was one of their
organizations ational colors and when
someone's going panicked like oh my gosh
I have this cancer diagnosis this is
scaring me seeing that red color is
going to connect to something deep
within their brain where they're going
to worry why is that heading in red well
the heading in red is just telling you
like what the tests mean and how they
work it's not bad I mean the whole
thing's bad but it's that that section
shouldn't be with some emotional tag
like red right so I'm really careful in
using those ALS o symbols you know an X
symbol should mean no or bad or don't
right a green check should mean you've
already done this an empty box should be
this is a thing you have to do right and
I've developed like um a consent forms
for please participate in our study same
kind of idea if there's a big warning
for privacy sections I will put that in
red if I have I'm allowed color because
I want people to go ooh attention this
could be bad right I want that attention
I so leveraging that color when you need
to invoke an emotion is really important
so that's kind of on the one side for
the the bad news type of diagnostic
diagnostic but for let's say maybe I
have some neurode Divergent people in my
audience or U maybe my I've had a boss
who was on um artism spectrum disorder
and would focus on things and I go why
are they focused oh okay that person
just is just looking at that quadrant
right like why are they always look at
that quadrant well one
I started to realize this person always
looked at that quadrant of a report so I
started putting the main information in
that quadrant of the report um so you
know working with individuals is easier
than working with a broad audience but
again when you're working at that broad
audience basically I assume I I'm in a
coding programming space the odds of
someone being neurodivergent in my
audience are reasonably high at any
given time so I'm always trying to make
sure again I'm waiting waiting
information in any presentation in the
same way I don't want to catch that
person my you know this person's
attention in the wrong section first
before I tell them the thing I want to
tell them and so in a presentation sense
or a presentation setting what's called
Progressive disclosure I'm sure you've
all used it that's the fancy term for it
if you want to sound you know wonkish um
but you have a slide right and you want
to say first we did this thing then we
did thing two then we did did thing
three do don't put things two and things
three on the slide only put here's the
order we did first we did thing one and
then tell them about thing
one and then make thing two appear and
then talk about thing two and then make
thing three appear so even in and I you
know fairly neurotypical I still have a
hard time when someone puts that on the
screen and it goes one two three I'm
going to go read they did one they did
two they did three and then I'm going to
change my attention back to the speaker
and so I've now lost everything they
said about thing one because I my brain
was focused on the Reading part it's
really hard even for the best
multitaskers above us to do two things
at once so making sure you're drawing
that attention both uh in a an orderly
way without giving later information
before you've given for first
information and then earlier information
and then the second side is using those
emotional and attention grabbing
cues very sparingly um so did that
answer a lot of that I hope
thank you that was really
helpful I see a lot of great thoughts
shared here in the chat too does anybody
want to jump in and and share what they
put in the chat too I don't mean I don't
want to just call on someone if you're
not ready to share but Ted I see you
unmuted so I'll have you jump in yeah so
I mean uh I discovered this when I I had
um a dyslexic student and she was kind
enough to explain to me what she was
having problems with
and I think it's you know after kind of
understanding like you know like it's
hard to kind of see things to group
things with dyslexia like you know that
was one of the things that I thought was
especially useful was using the Cordo
visual editor because she would always
kind of cut and paste code blocks and
accidentally copy the back ticks and
like she was wondering why it wasn't
working so it's just a little
accessibility thing so definitely thank
you um I'm gonna jump oh I was gonna
just say on on the like the dyslexia
component there are a lot of really cool
websites out there that show you
approximately what it's like to read if
you have dyslexia and those kind of help
me gain some empathy a long time ago
when I was working with that with that
that population in my health role um and
those were really helpful and also um
the uh font the type face design
Community spends way too much time too
much it's useful to me um thinking about
how to put space in letters and how you
can scan what letters are more easily
scannable some fonts are more easy to
read for dyslexic and they've dug into
why you know seraps and a fat serap and
a how you weight the letters and so if
you're really working you know you're
working with that group um there's so
much information on that especially in
the font and the type faed situation
highly recommend digging into um you'll
see I I use a lot of robato because
somewhere someone said that that was an
okay one for scab
um and reasonably good for dyslexics so
that's one I use as a core component for
my for my the meat of text when I'm
doing that so I never thought about
Corto being that which is brilliant I
love it thank you yeah I asked in the
chat too if if anybody had recommended
resources for this topic too and I see
uh a few suggestions there so thank you
so much Russ Stephen and Damian oh
there's more more and more coming in so
I'll make sure to capture those and put
pull them together as well
um a slido question that I saw come in
was Laura have you ever experienced a
conflict with the story you want to tell
and what the data actually says not
usually um
because let me put it this way many
times we we start with a hypothesis we
think thing a went great thing B went
bad but in the course of our analysis we
found it was the reverse right so
during the analysis I'm trying to test
my story about what do I want to talk
about this data and for the analyst in
the world you know there's uh
exploratory and explanatory data
analysis right and even when you do
explanatory data analysis you're still
doing a little bit of exploratory
because you're trying to figure out why
a thing happened and explain why that
thing happened in exploratory data
analysis you're just going well what
happened um so there is a story inherent
in the analysis and that comes from a
hypothesis right and often times you
know I don't know 60% of the time my
initial hypothesis is or 90% of the time
my initial hypothesis is not perfectly
solid right I was a little wrong we were
we found something different we didn't
have the data to prove a orb um and so I
will talk about that in my story if I
have enough time if I only have five
minutes to give a presentation or
present something or it's only a one
pager I'm not going to talk about that
whole thing but there are many times
where I've been wrong I my story that I
thought at the beginning is not the
story we found at the end and depending
on your audience you might want to build
that in because if I assumed that it was
thing a at the beginning I'm gonna guess
most people in my organization also
thought it was thing a at the beginning
so you may want to start you know
clickbait headlines worked for a reason
we've all caught wise to it but if you
thought it was say ay boy do I have news
for you come along on this journey and
you know that's obviously the
a little bit not the best lead for that
but working with that Arc especially if
you have the Right audience for it um
that might actually cement your final
actually it turned out to be thing B
better because everybody in the
organization knows it's thing a of
course it's thing a we just ask you to
go get the data on it because we're a
data driven organization and you're like
hey everybody we thought it was a it
really isn't and this is why and I want
to convince you it's thing B and you
have to take them on that Journey so
that they're with you they weren't in
that room when you did 40 50 100 hours
of work on the data they need to be
brought along you're you're giving them
the shortened version of that to get to
thing be so it's sort of you know I
there have been stories I've wanted to
tell but from my political situation I'm
not allowed to tell that story so we
kind of have to dance around it a little
bit but
usually the story I want to tell is the
story that we found in the data so so I
know it's kind of a washy answer
but thank you I see
um uh and jolly and apologies if I
mispronounced your name asked about if
you had any internship openings but I
thought this might be also a good time
to mention as well if anybody is hiring
for any roles feel free to share them in
the chat as well I I forgot to say that
in the beginning um but Laura wanted to
ask you specifically too yeah um we
let's see how to say this politically
correctly watch our website starting
early in the year um some things are
changing in good ways and we may or may
not have some positions coming up
opening for data type folks is that
watch the space
January sounds good um another slido
question um that came in and just a
reminder if anybody joined a little bit
after the start there's a few ways you
can ask questions here so feel free to
raise your hand on Zoom you put it in
this Zoom chat here but we also have the
slid link that Robert shared where you
can ask anonymously um but one over
there was what are a few of your go-to
tools for storytelling or reporting with
data yeah so
um for the me the person writing it I
always start with the I put blank slides
for the number of slides I need and then
I write as the header what point do I
want to make on that slide right we
started hypo in the organization we
think thing a next slide thing a
actually turned out to be false thing
slide see the journey you know we
started with this the data was here and
just kind of like the highlights you
know if you if you take a storytelling
course it's called the Beats of the
story right so you watch a movie you
know I know elf you know baby stolen
from home in Santa's bag baby finds out
human baby goes to you know as adult
goes to City finds dad you know Etc
whatever um so I kind of set my Beats on
my slides let's say or in a document
I'll just write the sentences that I
want to hit those beats and make them
make them headers um and then I go in
and okay what do I need to tell that
story point right well I need to tell
that this these three data points that
we usually rely on restricted doesn't
actually mean restricted from that
Financial code it means this kind of
thing so we did this thing and then you
know kind of build in what do I need to
prove that prove support the
underlying uh the support for that that
that story beat and then I'll work my
way through oftentimes I'm finding
myself writing like 40 or 50 words and I
go too many words either I need two
beats in the story or I need an image um
you know and you can always you know
line went up 15% that's an image
obviously um and there's a lot of good
information blog posted forthcoming
about how to tell certain stories you
can also story stories and data you know
bar charts great for context like
context contextual uh no categorical
there we go categorical right you want
to say we sold more tables than we did
chairs this month or what have you um
you can put changes in there there's a
whole world of that um but in those
beats I'll say I'm trying to prove month
over month there were more right so you
know I'll go into the the you know the
DAT of is Guru world and think about
okay I want to show their were more over
time how do people use that I'll browse
around and look oh on uh tidy Tuesday on
the old Twitter was great I'm hoping it
ends up somewhere um but I could
adventure
with what others were doing to show that
same kind of thing and sometimes I'd
stum stumble across a graph and I'd go
that tells me that story when I just
look at it I don't have to dig in um and
so I'll steal that information and put
it under my story beat so um so in terms
of making this de developing my whole
talk or my whole document or my whole
whatever I'm giving um to in terms of my
tools for that are work from a
storyteller's perspective work from a a
screenwriter's perspective essentially
and work with my story beats and then
from a data viz perspective there's a
lot of information out there but my
always my number one thing when it comes
to a data visualization is I'm going to
hold it up in front of a coworker for
two seconds and then put it down and I
want them to tell me what it was line
goes up line goes down way more of thing
a than the rest of the
things that's I just want that one hold
it up on a piece of paper move it down
what do you remember and if they don't
remember my Salient point line went up
line went down more of thing a than the
rest of the things I got to go back to
the drawing board on that graph right um
leverage Maps whenever you
can you get way more looking at a map of
the United States and health insurance
rates by County than you do a big old
table of the counties right so so
there's a whole world on that and
digging in is is kind of that way I hope
that answers that question it's a little
fumbly as well but I think I got there
happy to answer follow-ups
needed thank you yeah the point about
Maps is just making me think of last
week I during Thanksgiving I saw a map
of the US that said like which states
prefer like pecan pie vers apple pie
vers pumpkin pie and I can when you said
that I could just like very clearly see
it in my head and remember it yep um I
see let's see Alan you had a question in
the chat want to jump in here yeah sure
um this is super fun um I'm just really
really enjoying it Laura thanks um I'm
wondering so there are some rooms that
don't want the journey they want like
they want the executive summary like
whatever that means and I wonder if
you've got an approach or a toolkit or a
way to be informed about what does this
room want and therefore kind of how to
calibrate it so that you like do the
right kind of preparation and and you
come in with what they're looking for um
and uh you know if not how do you how do
you pivot when you run into that wall
when you uh you know when you start you
start to give the talk right and
immediately someone jumps in and says
you know and they just they just rabbit
hole into into something I'm wondering
how you prepare for that and how you
figure out how to how to respond yep um
so on the first half the prepping for
the room um Malcolm Hawker CDO matters
podcast he's a guy who works for a
prophecy um he used to work for Gartner
um I love listening to that podcast when
I run because it's a it helps me problem
solve and I I find myself debugging a
lot of code while listening to him um
but he has this this this thing he talks
about where it says um if my SE Suite
right now in my organization if I'm
developing something for them usually
where the request came down a couple
levels to me and said hey they want to
know this pivot table I'm like they
don't want to know the pivot table they
don't want the pivot they have a
business question they're asking and
they don't know how to ask down the
chain or someone down the chain doesn't
know how to ask down the chain um for
the spirit of the information so they
can only ask for the letter of the
information right there's business
question they don't want the data they
want to solve a business question and so
Malcolm Hawker says if you can get in
that room get in that room you're not
always going to be able in be able to in
the room but you can ask people who are
in the room or you can ask people who
work directly with someone who is in the
room you know there's a a VP and I talk
all the time with one of her her
assistant type people and so I always go
like hey what did what did um Sarah Jane
want Sarah Jane what's what's she
working on right now I've got a request
from her can you give give me any more
information on it and so leverage that
Network back up you're never working in
a Solo position ever I hope um if you're
an independent consultant you might be
but hopefully you've given a little bit
of of Leverage to at least ask some
people what's going on and help guide
you on the right track just to see oh
they're looking at this huge project
over here I don't know much about it but
it's all about the West Coast whatever
um so you can think okay let me
incorporate that into my synthesized
analysis for them to make sure I'm
hitting the spirit of the ask rather
than just the letter so that's one part
um the other part of the I think I've
got my great story I think I've got all
my data and all my story beats ready I
go into this meeting and on slide two
they go well of course it's thing a what
about thing C and I'm like I only
thought about A and B I didn't think
about c um the upside is if you are the
one that did the exploratory
analysis you probably saw something
related to it and I always hate giving
the answer
I don't know because sometimes you don't
know but you kind of have to say I don't
know but you can say oh well we there
were some inklings of things see here
were like we saw this or we don't
collect that data point that's why we
didn't talk about it but we could here
are some ideas that I've thought about
while drowning in your data earlier um
or you can kind of pivot a little um and
this is always why if I ever give a
presentation that I did not do more than
60% of the work on I have that person in
the room and I have been asked to
present for my team on many you know
there's I know five analysts working on
something and I'm just the one bringing
it all together I with every ounce of my
fiber and power I will have at least the
main analyst in the meeting with me and
I'll have a little side conversation
Allison hey can you step in here do you
got anything and Allison will be like
yeah cool and I'm like I'm GNA ask
Allison because Allison did the meat of
the work on the west coast and I'll Have
Allison come in um it never works well
you know when someone wants to spin
something off the rails um that's also
why at the top of every presentation I
start with my hypothesis I start with
the beginning of the story which was
someone said hey I'm wondering how we're
doing in
California um you know so I start there
and I say but it was it's only nor it's
only Northern California and then that's
the path I took because I don't want
them to think I didn't think about their
hypothesis to start with I want to make
sure that's all in there um and then the
other thing is in most rooms well you
know we only looked at these things
because that was our starting point uh
there was some information in there the
data wasn't great which is why we
pivoted away early but let let's talk
about this concept and then I'll take
your this conversation right now back to
the drawing board and we'll develop that
and give you a follow-up deck or
document or presentation um it it's led
to disappoint appointment in some
meetings I've had back when I was doing
more Consulting type work um but we
never really had anybody
mad um sometimes you're never going to
get everything so I hope that sort of
answers yeah yeah yeah absolutely yeah
thank
you thank you it was actually just
making me think too about even like
presentations that aren't like data
related but when you're showing somebody
something that you're really excited to
share them with them and then they have
great ideas because they got excited
sometimes I can get distracted by their
great ideas and wanting to address that
in the middle of the presentation as
well um I
see uh Jeff you had asked a question a
bit earlier do you want to jump in here
and Jeff I think it was around like
giving five minute talks let me try you
can jump in if you want to add more
context um but the question was Laura
what what would a five minute
presentation look
like the five minute so I'm gonna we're
GNA go back to my little fake example
here of we thought thing a and it ended
up being thing B right so if we're going
to talk in the meat of it and we're
going to get down for the analysts it's
going to take longer because they're
going to want to know every variable
right but if I'm just presenting to this
to the SE Suite or in my example of I
have five minutes to get a minister of
Health to sign off on this big spend to
fund my big research study or fund my
program over here
um the the starting point of that rather
than going through the the Beats of my
story the starting point is what do I
need them to know what do they
absolutely have to know when they walk
away from this this five minutes and
it's thing B was right even though we
all assumed it was thing a it was I need
half a million dollars because if I
don't fund this then this big thing is
going to happen you know I need the
thing I need you to know this thing and
if you always go back to that touch
point in your five minutes then you'll
be successful and then with that touch
Point make your little mini story right
you start with hey Minister I need you
to know thing B I got five minutes to
convince you here's my five minutes you
know we all thought it was thing a we
did some analysis and I'm very happy to
present you a longer document we have
later but the main points were the data
we had to support thing a was wrong uh
when we started to look into it it
really turned out to be thing be even
though the population was smaller um and
then we uh also were looking at this
other thing and to solve thing B we need
this money and so rather than I'm
writing my my story beats and filling in
underneath it's I'm starting with the
absolutely critical thing that they need
to know and then building from there
right building the mini story underneath
it everything has to point back to that
Salient Point um so it's all you know
with the the line um if i' had more time
I would have written a shorter letter
it's the same thing is it takes way more
work to do five minutes than it does to
do 25 minutes so plan accordingly
awesome thank you Eugene I see you had a
question want to jump in here yes so um
in my experience I've uh sort of
witnessed that in the modern you know
last decade and a half of of just data
uh becoming the the reason that people
choose their business action or um
policy actions that everyone is just
becoming a little more data Savvy and
you know the leadership sort of really
starts to cling to you know data and
want to use that data to support their
decision- making um and so Junior
analysts or other people on the team
will get
blindsided rather fast sometimes by the
leader that you know becomes more and
more data savvy so they start asking for
more slices more interactivity so they
could find this stuff out literally in
the meeting you know when when you're
presenting this stuff so how do you um
help you what what's your way of I think
helping teammates because I I think
through what you're talking about it's
pretty obvious you're you're already
doing this yourself you're thinking
about this yourself but um I think
teammates yeah you know younger people
who who sort of are looking to that
leadership are are trying to figure out
how to be ahead of those questions and
I don't think that's an easy thing for
them to get a grip on until they've been
sort of burned you know like 10 times so
I'm just curious if you have some
strategies to keep people ahead of these
you know Lites that become more and more
and more data Savvy and start asking for
more and more complex stuff that that
takes the data analysts much more time
to peel apart yeah absolutely um so
again as I tend to do I split it into
two parts so I'm going to start with the
the easier part which is um how to get
ahead of the of the questions you're
going to ask um so you know let's say
I'm a middle person between a junior and
a senior member and that senior member
is the or that VP let's say is the one
that always asks way too detailed
questions I'm gonna make sure I'm
working with that Junior member to know
hey you know uh VP Jane VP Jane asks all
the details right she's gonna get in the
weeds with you be prepared to get in the
weeds with her because she's leading
this meeting um and never just be able
to never respond to Jane respond to Jane
okay let's have a conversation you know
off of the like sidebar on this and let
me get into this details with you and we
can walk together through this it might
not be worth building a whole dashboard
for Jane because really Jane has an idea
in the back of her head that she's
trying to get out with the well I want
to segment it like this and Jane doesn't
need to segment it like that she's just
wondering like what happened to this
group of people right so maybe you don't
need to build a dashboard for and use
all that time but I've had good
experience with people who are really
are data savvy
that they're good with me live coding
with them right they don't need a whole
dashboard where they can interact um
they're often times okay with me just
doing some live Co like hey cut it like
this and show me what that cross tab
table looks like and they're they're
great with it um so prepping that Junior
member saying Jane asks the questions
she's going to want you to go two steps
farther than you did so prepare to get
ready to go two steps further or
especially if you have a good
relationship say hey Jane let me you and
this junior member the three of us are
going to have a meeting and we'll cut
this every way you want in this one hour
shared meeting um and I've had really
good results with that especially with
truly data Savvy people the problematic
side of this is uh throughout my entire
career I have worked with many people
who are data Savvy in that they can use
curated products for themselves but they
cannot use the chaotic mess right I am
right now in a chaotic mess of an
organization it is very hard to rapidly
turn around around some results for
people who are like we're a big
organization why can't I just know how
many constituents we have anybody who's
in data think about how many
constituents do you have your
organization what do you mean Finance
has a different definition does than
does product sales than does you know
the fundraising side you know we've got
volunteers as a PE as a a constituent
we've got service members as a
constituent we've got donors as a
constituent we've got Congressional
members as
constituents what is a constituent in
our organization that's a hard problem
and it sounds like it should be easy um
especially if you've always been served
good data products you know a great
solidly data data an Enterprise data
level organization um so that's where
I've run into the problem is where
people go well give me all the data but
they don't know the context of the data
they're used to using a curated data
product they're they're used to a
working they're used to the more of a
data scientist role than like an
analytic engineer role right they came
up through the data science but they
don't know how all this control for
processes work and why it doesn't talk
to each other um that's where I've
struggled and if anybody has a good
ideas on that one because you can't
exactly tell your
CEO no you don't understand what you're
talking about you have to answer that
CEO's question as best you can without
giving him here's 22 million rows of
data have at it Mr CEO I don't know what
to tell you uh because you'll go a
little crazy and you also don't want to
spend you know hundreds of analyst and
Dev hours building a dashboard for
something when he only wanted that one
question or he's never going to use it
it's going to go to the graveyard of
dashboards so if anybody has any good
ideas on those folks that are genuinely
good-hearted and best intentions it's
just they're only used to working with
beautiful data products anyone
anyone I'll walk I'll watch for unmutes
to see if anybody wants to jump in on
this but I saw um Philip I was going to
quickly say you could scare them with uh
the rough you know
consolas uh font output of a table uh
table function that you're running R and
just snapshot and drop it to them scare
them a
yeah little bit of a red flag back off I
know what I'm doing tell me your
business problem and I'll help you but
just give me data it doesn't work
yeah Philip I I see you had a um like a
follow along question to you Jean's
question and just wanted to make sure we
cover that in the the answer too and I
heard somebody was about to jump in so
I'll have you jump in first and then
we'll we'll jump over there then I was
just saying that i' I've run into some
folks that were more of let's just why
don't you look at the data as a data
scientist and you tell me what our
problem should be that we're solving one
part lucky and one part me at my pay
level you want me to the strategy the
org I mean cool but you get the well
you're good at looking at things and
understanding how data you know getting
answers from data you should be able to
also come up with the questions that's
something I've run into with with
certain Executives where that that's
that's one that's you there's nuances to
navigating
that and now I'm curious what how do you
navigate that I go back to I need to
understand what we're trying to
accomplish
because you know that's that's the lens
through which I will view the data
without that it's all just blurry to me
it also sounds like you've been cursed
by being good at your job I've I've also
got 27 years in the same industry so I
ALS I have a fair amount of domain
knowledge so that's
where that that's where that's coming in
really yeah I think this may have been
addressed a bit in the answer but I saw
Philip had said cool question Eugene so
added on to it um and said we get a lot
of Workshop like meetings where you get
a broad question thrown at you and doing
the explorations and a lengthy meeting
with management how would you prepare or
anticipate for that type of meeting
anything you want to add to that yeah
just the way I've done it is you know
make sure you've got all your you know
if you're small world non-enterprise
make sure it's all in your desktop in
your environment ready to go make sure
you've got it pushed to something like a
parquet file that's really rapidly
pivotable especially if you've got big
big data sets um you know if you're
lucky to work in you know we work in
data bricks we've got a Unity catalog so
I can go connect to everything that I
have permission for um I also have a
great partnership with it so I know what
data is available if I have a reason to
ask for it and so if I'm in that meeting
and they go what about the volunteers oh
well if you'd like that just send me an
email and we'll get the it to approve my
my need for that but you know because we
have you know security permissions and
silid silid silid I haven't had access
to that um so really um those those
types of meetings and I've had several
of them like my example with you know
Jane the VP and a junior member um live
coding just like slash it this way um
it's
been like make sure that your you know
digital desktop of all of your things
everything's Within Reach of you um to
be ready to go um and then you you're
both going to do your best to answer
that VP that VP Jane's questions um but
also you're going to be seen as someone
who can get stuff done really quickly
and so questions might come out of that
um that help you do the rest of your job
um so I those are stressful hard hours
they are really hard and you have to be
quick and on your toes and know
everything's right there you can just
grab it you know I can just grab you
know whatever my hair tie or whatever I
can grab it um and then serve the
information quickly and if I can't
totally serve the information quickly we
have that question that hypothesis that
we know Jane is curious about um and so
those are so tough and if you get to go
into one of those it's probably going to
be really hard and really really useful
so any chance you have for one of those
grab it if you don't have Tim's 27 years
in the business and know a lot of it
already if you're in that one well I
think if you've got those 27 years of
experience I think you've got a little
bit of a a leg up on some of that thank
you I see let's see um Sarah I see you
asked a question in the chat I'll read
it because I see the little star here um
but the question was I work in academic
research as a grad student and I often
have trouble telling a story because it
takes so long to get people the
scientific background they need to
actually care about the problem we are
solving
computationally any advice on keeping
the background engaging or working it
into the story along with the data take
the the time take your time and practice
on your friends my sister heard 400
versions of my doctoral dissertation
presentation conservatively um because I
kept testing messages on her and she
understood virtually nothing of what I
actually did by the end of it she
understood a lot of it but not a lot um
the uh but that that idea of that
background is huge to get to we went
here
um always that then that's part of like
why I have the story beats what do I
need them to know as we go along on this
slide I need to take two minutes to make
sure they
know Gene
abc4 is critical in these 11 diseases
right do I need them to know abc4 up
regulates this and down regulates this
but when it down regulates this it then
up regulates these two other things do I
need them to know that it down and up
regulates all of these certain things
Maybe not maybe I just need them to know
that ABC does is is involved in some way
in these nine conditions um if you need
to talk about each way of those
conditions because it has an impact
later right maybe it's these five
conditions it's an up regulator and
these three these three it's a down
regulator that's that critical component
and later when we're talking about our
analysis we found it affected only down
Regulators not up Regulators well then
you need to spend a little more time on
that touch point but building from a
story beat
and everything within that story beat of
service of that beat is a good is a good
way to tie it back and then of course
practice on someone who doesn't know
anything find your best friend who works
in she's a finance person and you're a
geneticist tell your Finance friend
about it and see if she can follow the
story even though she doesn't have the
detail right and then get your lab
partner you know and say hey lab partner
when I tell you the story does it remain
faithful to the extreme detail because
there's always going to be an
abstraction there was a great um when
all the posit talks are up there was a
great um talk about leaky abstractions
one of the Keynotes I think um wonderful
talk go pay attention to that talk um
but I always now I'm trying to pay
attention to where my abstracts might my
abstractions might be leaky and give a
little note maybe it's just a little
footnote of just hey there's a thing you
might want to pay attention this is a
generalization but up regulator down
regulator and this is where the change
is there's some down Reg in these do
they need to know maybe not so it sort
of go back to that make sure you're
hitting your touch points and if it's
the five minute it's in service of that
key message if it's the longer
presentation of your story
beats thank you I uh I don't always get
to read the chat while the Hangouts are
happening but I just wanted to remind
people you can save the chat because
they see there's a lot of great
resources being shared in there there's
that little um three dots at the bottom
of the chat where you can save it but I
was laughing at these office jargon
phrases that you all are office jargon
that you're all sharing there like
boiling the ocean and all the loow
hanging
fruit there's there's quite a few in in
there um Ethan I I see you asked a
question a bit earlier in the chat do
you want to jump in here yeah sure um
Laura I was just curious if you're if
you're giving like a slide slide deck
presentation to what extent do you
utilize an appendix where you have
slides on details whether that's details
you feel like you have to present to
validate some of the stuff you're doing
or the points you're making or just
questions you anticipate to what extent
do you utilize that or do you try to
keep the presentation really really
clean and save all that stuff for just
if there's a follow-up question on
it I always have extra slides because
again my original presentations are
always like an hour and a half so as I'm
building I want to put my Gene example
you know here's the gene ABC it's in
these five and these three I'm going to
want to tell you 400 things about all of
these things all eight of these I'm
going to want to tell you it does it's
mostly a down regular but it does these
nine nine other things and this one
actually is involved in this thing but
not these things and sometimes only in
men but not usually whatever I'm going
to want to tell you a lot of stuff about
these eight right and so when I build my
original talk I'm going to overbuild
that slide and then when I go back
through my cleaning round again if I had
more time I would have written a shorter
letter I'll go back again and say okay I
have six slides for this these saying
ABC is related to these eight what in
here doesn't go back to that touch point
of I need you to know ABC is involved in
a lot that continues the rest of my
story and I'll have a slide on each of
these eight things all of those go into
the appendix all of those are for later
slides because someone in that room to
someone's Point earlier might want to
try and throw me off well you didn't
consider that thing that second thing is
a really a you said it's an up regulator
but it downregulates these 400 other
things well hey Mr you know guy here's
here's the slide that shows why I'm
putting it in the upregulator category
right so when Mr snoody guy wants to
throw you under the bus you've got those
slides where you can go Mr snoody
we we this is why I put it over there um
super happy to have more conversations
with you about this but really we're
here to talk about the whatever I said
those down regulating three and that's
why I got put up here um so I use them
all the time and usually because I
started way too long and they got pulled
back I will make sure some of that might
be really really needed right to tell
the whole story some of that thing about
thing two being an up and down whatever
I made up that might be really critical
to to the rest of the story of why it
went up here and not over here right so
I need to include that information
because it's in service to that story
point I need to tell um so it might stay
in and then I have to shorten another 10
minutes somewhere in that speech I'm
gonna have to drop some information but
if you're only given 10 minutes to
talk you absolutely Cann not tell the
full story of an entire Gene not going
to happen right no chance in help they
didn't give me enough
so going back to the what do they need
to know and what are the story boards
story points to get there service of
that and then you've got that extra
stuff that you had to cut out cut to
size in your
appendix I may or may not cut those
appendix slides out if I have to share
like great I want your slides I might
not include those if it's a recorded
talk and we talked about that second
thing I'll put that slide in at the end
so that if they're watching a video they
can see that slide or if we want to talk
talk more about that slide I'll put it
in the middle and then we can that can
spur more conversations um but I almost
always have extra stuff that just made
my talk too
long I can't believe how fast this hour
is going by right now um but I I know I
said in the beginning here I love in the
in the Hangouts where we get to kind of
just get like a little snippet into what
life is like as a data scientists in
different Industries and I was just
curious if you could share like a
highlevel project that you might work on
in your role not without going into like
specifics of course but just kind of
giving us a glimpse into to it yeah um
so because I'm on the development
operation side um the like the number
one thing is where did we get our money
and from who and are there you know we
have managed donors you know Joe
billionaire is going to have a special
fundraiser assigned to them but if
you're just giving us $200 at the end of
the year you'll get a nice thank you and
maybe a Christmas ornament but we're not
we don't have a person managing you
right to make sure that we have a good
relationship this is the same through
all any nonprofit that does fundraising
it's the same kind of idea but there's
also that middle group of people of well
maybe they're writing us $3,000 checks
every year should we put him in the
should we give him a fundraiser or maybe
not or this guy only gives us $25 a
month you know this lady gives us $25 a
month every month and has for 10 years
but our wealth rating says she's got a
lot of money in the bank and she seems
to be 82 years old maybe we should talk
to her about a bequest so let's put a
person on her even though she's a small
Giver so broadly my reports fall into
like three categories like how are we
raising money and that might be a big
you know quarterly report or uh
something to go into a Grant application
um and then how are our fundraisers
doing with their portfolios and then
what about these middle people that
maybe we should have a guy on can you go
like dig into into that middle slice
that middle demographic and find us some
people that maybe want to check out and
do some research on um so it kind of
falls into those three and I generally
am only reporting in the fundraising the
fundraiser space I don't do a whole lot
on like the how many people clicked on
this Instagram ad versus the dog
Instagram ad versus the Veterans Day
Instagram ad we have another team that
does that kind of the direct response
kind of stuff we I work in the
fundraising world so bringing Lots stuff
weird stuff together and saying is this
person is this John Smith the same as
that John Smith uh we do lots of the
John Smith problem um which I'm sure
anybody who's taking a data set classes
done that and also set your hair on fire
for how many constituents do we have I
don't know are these 84 people the same
John Smith your guess is as good as mine
so a lot of that
world great thank you so much Laura I I
see there's a few questions that um we
might not get to I just saw a few from
the the chat but I just wanted to give
everybody the opportunity like we have a
few minutes left if you want to raise
your hand here if there was a question
that we didn't get to of
yours and I'll just keep an eye out
while I ask this one I see Joseph asked
and put a little star there so I'll read
it um I have a team member who wants to
add tool tips to everything but I worry
that some audiences are overwhelmed by
those details or that adding those
options make some people dive deep too
quickly without seeing the big picture
in the visualization do you have a way
of thinking about when tool tips or a
table view are useful and when they're
distracting yeah that's always the a lot
of the times I go we should but we
shouldn't and I fight myself into a
circle and then at the end of the day
the highest title in the room is the one
that decides whether or not we have them
if the CEO wants all of them they're
going in I spend some sometime maybe
designing that tool tip so that it's
less intrusive or it's easier to scan
and again in product design worlds you
know there's lots of talk about how the
nutrient label on food how scannable is
that how does that that's a tool tip on
a physical product right so I spend some
time designing how that tool tip might
pop up um but if the you know the CEO
wants it it's happening if a low-level
analyst wants it or not low level but
down the chain analyst and this is being
delivered to
everybody maybe I turn it off for
everybody but offer a you know a
packaged version to that analyst who
really wants to do some exploration um
if I can get the you know the space on
all of our servers I'll have two
versions of that dashboard the executive
version and the analyst version um and
so sometimes you know the CEO wants this
is what you get shared at unless you ask
too many questions then we give you this
one which hopefully Spurs more questions
so it almost ends up as the highest
title in the room and then if I have
fellow curious d to people that I try
and serve them because they're trying to
answer questions too or find more
questions so kind of a a wishy-washy
answer on that one but sometimes that's
what it
is thank you so much Laura um as we get
to the end here I'm just wondering if
people want to connect with you what's
the best way is it LinkedIn or through
your blog or um yeah LinkedIn or I'm on
threads but my threads is kind of not
professional but I feel like this is not
professional you know this is fun nerds
making jokes about bad product design so
absolutely linkedin's the best the
easiest place in a professional
capacity awesome I did just want to
share we do have a data science hangout
Community LinkedIn group maybe sometimes
not the best way to have back and forth
conversation but we try sometimes but I
shared it in the chat there if anybody
wants to join that group to make it
easier to connect with each other as
well I love getting to hear about people
who are friends now because they met in
the data science hangout or maybe met
each other yeah in the chat sharing
resources but thank you so much Laura
for joining us today and and sharing
your experience this has been so fun
absolutely thank you everyone and I'm
very open to questions on LinkedIn just
just send me
questions awesome well thank you all
have a great rest of the day so nice to
see you bye everyone
bye